a parte se encuentra el valor de campo
para el cual la función efe tiene un
punto crítico en x igual a menos 5 y
bien lo primero que hice fue copiar aquí
la función fx que es igual a 1 / x
cuadrada - k x y también copie la
función f prima de x que es cada menos
2x / x cuadrada
- k x todo esto elevado al cuadrado esta
información nos la dan al principio del
problema muy bien así que con estas dos
funciones lo que quiero encontrar es el
valor de camps para el cual la función
ftx tiene un punto crítico en x igual a
menos 5 y bueno si nosotros queremos que
f tenga un punto crítico en x igual a
menos 5 eso qué significa
déjame ponerlo aquí
efe tiene un punto crítico
x igual a menos 5 si pasan dos cosas así
que las voy a poner aquí la primera de
ellas es que este valor de x igual a
menos 5 debe de estar en el dominio así
que voy a ponerle que está en el dominio
es decir significa que la función está
definida en este punto x igual a menos 5
y lo segundo que se tiene que cumplir es
que f prima de menos 5 tiene que ser
igual a 0 o en su dado caso f prima de
menos 5 tiene que ser indefinida
d
fin
me da muy bien efe prima evaluada en
este punto x
250 o f prima evaluada en este punto x
igual a menos 5 es indefinida porque
recuerda un punto crítico es un miembro
del dominio de una función en el cual la
derivada de la función aplicada al punto
debe de ser igual a 0 o debe de ser
indefinida así que qué te parece si
evaluamos a efe prima de x en equis
igual a menos 5 y para eso tenemos aquí
a efe prima de x entonces voy a evaluar
f prima de menos 5 y bueno esto me va a
quedar lo mismo que si sustituyó el
valor de x por menos 5 aquí que me va a
quedar me va a quedar acá menos 2 que
multiplica a menos 5 muy bien
y esto a su vez está dividido entre -5
esto elevado al cuadrado menos camps que
multiplica al menos 5 y después todo
esto está elevado al cuadrado
todo esto está elevado al cuadrado bien
y ahora ya tenemos esta función escrita
en términos de cama bueno esto se puede
reducir un poco me quedaría lo mismo que
acá menos por menos es más camas 10 esto
dividido entre y aquí tengo bueno aquí
me quedarían 25
+ 5 veces camps
todo esto elevado al cuadrado entonces
qué valor de cam hacen que f prima de
menos 5 que esto de aquí sea igual a 0
bueno pues si f prima de menos 5 es
igual a 0
eso quiere decir que acá más 10 tendría
que ser igual a cero esto implica que
cada más 10 tiene que ser igual a 0
aunque camps tomaría el valor de menos
10 estás de acuerdo
este es el valor de acá para el cual
afecten de un punto crítico en x igual a
menos 5 y bueno tiene un punto crítico
en x igual a menos 5 porque este
numerador lo hicimos igual a 0 y
entonces este valor de camps es el valor
que hacen que esté numerador de esta
fracción sea igual a 0 y por eso hace a
efe prima de menos 5 igual
y bueno tal vez estés pensando que
valores de campo hacen que la derivada
de la función evaluada en x igual a
menos 5 sea indefinida y bueno para
contestar eso déjame bajar un poco la
pantalla para contestar eso podemos
hacer lo siguiente ahora queremos ver
para que camps f prima de menos 5 esto
es indefinido
y d
fin
'vida y bueno es indefinida cuando la
parte de acá abajo es igual a cero es
decir cuando acá toma el valor de menos
cinco porque si tienes 25 más sin tocar
igual a cero eso quiere decir que camps
tomaría el valor de menos 5 entonces
podemos decir que f prima de menos 5 es
indefinida cuando camps toma este valor
y hasta que todo bien pero ojo ten
cuidado porque si cada toma el valor de
menos 5 entonces x igual a 5 no es un
punto crítico porque porque no estaría
en el dominio observa que si acá vale
menos 5 entonces cómo se vería efe de x
bueno pues fx se vería de la forma
fx se vería de la forma 1 entre x
cuadrada
más porque aquí tenemos un signo de
menos menos por menos me da más más 5x y
observa que en este caso cuando x toma
el valor de menos 5 la parte de acá
abajo se hace igual a 0 me quedaría 1
entre 25 menos 25 lo cual no está
definido entonces acá igual a menos 5 no
hace a x igual a menos 5 un punto
crítico porque no estaría en el dominio
entonces recuerdan y esto es muy
importante para tener un punto crítico
se deben de cumplir dos cosas primero
que ese valor de x esté en el dominio y
segundo que la derivada en ese punto sea
igual a cero o sea indefinida así que en
este caso cuando acá vale igual a menos
5 se tiene que la derivada es indefinida
pero si k es igual a menos cinco
entonces x igual a menos 5 no es
en el dominio entonces en este caso no
tendríamos un punto crítico por lo tanto
podemos decir que mi único resultado de
este inciso c es k igual a 10 porque en
este caso tenemos que la primera
derivada evaluada al menos 5 es igual a
cero y menos 5 si está en el dominio así
que esta es la respuesta